welcome to the latest edition of just
getting started it's episode 11
right here on this podcast and it's
gonna be a fun one i've known this man
for a very long time which he heard
how i met him and how i know him and uh
why i adore him in so many different
ways he's got a new podcast himself
called here for you
and i hope you're ready for a laugh
because he's going to provide many of
them here on this episode of just
getting started my friend bob saggett
[Music]
here's my guest on just getting started
i love this man he is one of the best
human beings on the planet
not only because i've known him a long
time but also he was at my bachelor
party and he's kept quiet about it ever
since
and he's got a podcast that uh
is dynamite podcast he is here for us
right now he's bob saget how are you bob
i'm good rich when i see you i miss you
horrifically you know what it's funny um
i'll tell this story
uh i have known you i've been married
what she's uh coming up on 20 years and
i've known you before that
i've known you that long um but um and
and there's few people who i adore
like you bob and this is a perfect story
for it
here i am uh in cleveland ohio just two
weeks ago getting ready to do the nfl
draft
and it's a big bear of an assignment i
mean literally a huge assignment for me
it's hours upon hours upon hours of
preparation
on top of actually trying to execute it
uh with aplomb and professionalism
right uh and energy as i possibly can
and i look down at my phone
and i'm wondering who the hell is
calling me literally who the hell is
calling me
and there's few people i would actually
answer my phone for it's obviously my
wife susie who you've known longer than
me
and love very much my mother uh is one
i love very much and
names anyone else anyone else true and
then
and then it's b i look down at my phone
and it says bob
saget is calling and i honestly answered
the phone and i said is this your ass
calling me
or is this really you calling me like i
thought it and it was you calling me bob
it was legit yeah but i was using my ass
to call you i
i'm able to do that when i butt dial i
actually dial with my butt
that's impressive that you would be able
to do that but you were calling me
because you were you're about to go on
on uh philadelphia radio or something
like that no it was barstool's barstool
sports
yeah because i'm an eagles fan
right but i wasn't current on the draft
picks
at all but you weren't though you gave
me two or three choices like which one's
it gonna be
and i you know i gave you a couple of
them and if i'm not mistaken
uh you you already had the one that that
they chose is that well i actually had
spoken to
here we go history uh i had spoken to
michael price
who uh is a philadelphia eagles fan yes
and
a friend and he gave me some intel but
then i thought to myself
i'm i i'm i'm desperate
i i need more and so i knew you were in
the middle of it i knew it because i
i i looked i went right to your page and
i knew that you were in the middle of it
but i figured
maybe he'll answer and just go just
leave me alone okay
please just uh here but you gave me a
lot
and you even told me uh a phrase about
one of the gentlemen
but actually i picked i picked the the
gentleman
you did you picked devonta smith you
picked i did and
they freaked out and uh it was and i
freaked out because
thank you and then i showed this
on the air which only you could see
which is an eagles fan
card yes it is i'm in like a tuxedo
because that's the only picture we had
at the time
instead of a jersey that says eagles on
it and uh
everybody since i did that uh bar stool
sports thing has been
asking for how much are those cards i'm
not selling them i mean i'd mail them to
people
you know it's funny that i had i had the
same i still have them
fan of the game cards and uh god bless
my late dad
he would give them out to people who
would come to the house and recognize my
photograph on the pictures that they had
in his uh in his house and his condom
and they'd be and they said oh is that
your son the guy from nfl network and
he'd say yes
and if they did a good job he'd give
them a card
if they didn't go to do a good job screw
it he was not giving he was not wasting
so basically he would call up and say so
you know who came to the house
you know we needed something to do we
had a plumber come to the house a big
fan of yours i'm like dad was he card
worthy yes he was card worthy he gave
them a fan of the game
he had literally like a stack of them he
was the only human being on the planet
who had these fan of the game cards
so my parents did your parents have a
museum
in the house basically dedicated to you
yeah a shrine
i i was all over the house there were tv
guide covers there's newspaper articles
she had
my mother had a file on me yeah i'm like
do you work for the cia
or or i mean what are you doing to work
for variety as an intern
what are you doing and then my dad would
be so i saw you on television today and
i'm like yeah that's that's you know dad
what i do
that's what i you know knock on wood
what i do for a living here right so i
saw you on tv wow
boy you know you you wore a sharp shirt
today like literally that's the sort of
stuff i would get from mike
mine was um mine was my mother saying uh
i'm gonna have to her voice
she went bobby could you do me a favor i
saw you on the tonight show
you were very good but could you please
stop saying that i wear a viking helmet
and cool lots and tip plates
please don't say tit plates because they
let me say it and they didn't bleep it
but it was about my mom and that's
always kind of got me into trouble
uh you know and it's not always directed
at the right people
so i have learned a lot i've learned a
lot
i had an hbo special once where i did a
bit about
my middle daughter who's all my
daughters are brilliant and
wonderful and enabled women i mean 34 31
28. hike that and
the the middle one i had talked about
doing the laundry
and there was a thong in the laundry and
i was just doing a dad
joke which was i'm doing the laundry i'm
a single dad at the time
and uh was for a long time for 23 years
since uh their mom and i got divorced
then
we just were talking a minute before we
started this podcast so yes we're
friends and uh i know you didn't ask but
um that's what's great about having me
as a guest you can go on hiatus
yeah i'm gonna get something to drink
but i love it it's great hold on go to
the bathroom i'll be right back
but but i i ended up saying that doing
the laundry it wasn't a thong it looked
more like an eye patch for a pirate and
i started going i
and my daughter said she got so much
crap in school for that
and that's when i think there was a
after that special there was a turning
point in a lot of the stuff
that i said uh as i got older and then
i i got roasted and then that i had no
control and and i actually
didn't like some of the roasts are cruel
and right
yeah and they shouldn't be televised
actually well you got to speak to your
buddy jeff ross about that sort of thing
jeff's amazing at it you know and greg
geraldo was amazing and nikki glazer is
fantastic you know
certain people are just so great at it
um
but you know i i would know how to do it
now a little better but
sitting there and taking the beating
that's uh that's enough of that
right so uh the pod here called just
getting started
how did you get started bob sagan how
did i what's your start but
before on the podcast before quarantine
i um wanted to do a podcast i've been
out touring doing stand-up and
thank god i'm going back again uh now i
started a couple weeks ago
and i'm going to houston uh i
think it's a couple weeks i'm in houston
and i'm playing a bunch of clubs because
theaters can't open
i mean so in the fall i go into theaters
as well
no but i i meant i meant how did you get
started in your career we'll get to your
podcast
oh my whole career i think yeah
i'm talking about my podcast is called
just getting started there's the there's
the there's so the theme
of the podcast yes sir is your podcast
yes yes is how did you
your guest get started yes
and then and then we'll get to the here
and now later on okay yeah right before
quarantine
it's a guy that no matter what stage of
the answer
no no you let me finish the sentence i
was born
i was born uh 64 years before quarantine
yes from dolly saget
and uh and i was her uh
fourth child and um and it was a
difficult uh birth because uh
she was my mother and
and i loved her a lot i had a great dad
and then
i was always trying to make friends and
and i made eight millimeter movies and
put
friends in them since i was nine years
old and made 60 hours
of eight millimeter super eight and then
started to get into 16 millimeter
and then i moved in the middle of ninth
grade in the middle
from norfolk virginia to encino
california to learn materialism
properly and then in the middle of 11th
grade
and 12th i moved back from encino to
philly where i was born
and went to uh abington high and
and to make friends i made movies and
put people in these movies
and then when i moved back to philly i
started doing stand-up
just started doing it um did comedy
songs
and i won a wmmr radio contest
at a club called grandma minis who had
seen the unknown comic perform at and
then they said there was an open mic and
you could win 500
and i won the contest for singing a song
about
bondage where did bob's comedy come from
17 year old guy singing a song about
bondage
do you bondage good clean fun it's
bondage for everyone masochists and
sadists unite one at all bondas is the
rage come on let's have a ball
[Music]
uh do you have your guitar were you
playing your guitar oh yeah okay
what else am i gonna do that would have
just bombed
[Applause]
and it was i the joke was it's a 17 year
old with a comb over and welding glasses
singing a song about bondage you know
super nerd so i would always have a sick
sense of humor
got it from my dad and it's how we got
through life
and uh because we had a lot a lot of
tragedies so
then i would take the train to new york
and wait in line 12 hours do the sign up
sheet at catch rising star in the improv
and then at the same time you ask the
question it's the name of your podcast
this is great the answer is longer than
the podcast and then
i i went to school at temple university
was a pre-med student
sucked at that because i don't know what
numbers are and then
i do if it's an f-stop or a lens size so
i went to the film school
and made a documentary and won the
student academy award for
a doc i made about my nephew adam who
you know you met adam
and he's doing really well and he went
through surgery that's what the movie
was about face surgery it was very
serious
documentary and he narrated it that's
why it won anything because adam was
is a very special guy right so you're so
you're doing all this stuff
and let me just pause for a second and
so you're taking the train
while you're a pre-med to figure out if
you really want to do this or you knew
from the very
beginning this is what you wanted to do
like why not
why that did not know i swear to god i
didn't know i want to be a doctor i
wanted to help people
and then for some reason i found out
comedy kind of can do that in a weird
way
sure but especially if you're operating
on their lungs
i'm not a licensed doctor but i am gonna
i'm gonna cut you open and tell your
jokes um
so when people in my audience have
trouble breathing i just go and cut the
trach
i go right in i do what a paramedic
would do
um but i uh also did
improv comedy uh sketches long sketches
uh with a group called mixed nuts uh
that were university of pennsylvania so
i was one of the few temple people
or out of any school outside of u of p
that got to perform in their all-star
review their big show
and um so i was doing improv studying
film
and making films or trying if you call
them films
and doing stand-up so it was all i i
developed
an act steven starr the restaurateur i
owned a comedy club called stars and i
opened for
uh frank stallone and valentine and
i i opened for rich hall who used it all
for minnesota
again sure really funny guy i knew him
from early days at stars at this club
and so i was a philly i i
i grinded my eye teeth right
well i was welding and i had the grinder
i got nothing but that's what happened
that's how funny i was so
they came to l.a right and then then you
come to l.a and then you hit it it's
like
because again i guess because we had
bill burr on a couple of episodes
ago bob and he remembered a time where
it was snowing outside you know he's up
there in boston he had a gig in
providence and he literally thought you
know like
do i stay at home and it's nice and warm
and i could you know drink it's right
around you know the holidays and do his
reveling
or do i get in the car and i gotta this
is the gig this is the life i chose
and he got in the car like and did you
have any moments like that
for yourself where you thought mine was
accidental i mean i i came to l.a i
didn't go to my
graduation from temple university
because i won the student
oscar so the academy flew me out with
nine other winners
and i met howard koch who was the
president
at the time of the academy and
the head of paramount and um steven
spielberg i met
after close encounters is when i met him
and and i met all these people and then
i went up at the comedy store because i
brought my guitar
and and i would sing while my guitar
gently weeps and turn a valve and water
would pour out of the guitar
that's you had to be within the first
two rows there's no joke
i mean it's not a magic act and props
are not well thought of
and music acts are right above mime to
some people
but i wrote good comedy songs i thought
and it
it worked out and the owner of the
comedy store mitzi
said you shouldn't go to i was going to
go to usc grad school you shouldn't go
to grad school
you should work here and i went okay
and then the next night i got a spot
and letterman was my first emcee
it was do you want me to leave no that's
oh
that's a tournament that's a phrase i
don't know a lot of phrases no
so letterman get out of town yeah
get on a train all of a sudden you're
taking it too literally
so letterman was the letterman was the
emcee of your first
he was yeah he was and he was a hero the
moment i saw him i mean he was like one
of the stars of the store
and leno was there and michael keaton
and billy crystal
all these people were there and that
week within the first two weeks i met
robin
and i met richard and williams
those are the people or richard pryor
and um and robin williams
and um and i knew them my whole
uh career so it's
yeah so that was i literally was like a
guy
that had weird stuff that i said i just
said
weird stuff i didn't curse a lot but i
did when i was allowed to
you know when i was on the road i was
like a headliner right away in my early
20s because i was on make me laugh
show me i remember that show sure of
course yeah
bobby van is the host of that show sweet
sweet guy
and a lot of comics bruce baum baby man
bomb helped me get on there and that
show had
gary shandling on it and howie mandel
and the unknown comic was one of the
popular ones murray langston
and god a lot of people were on it mike
binder
um and marty cohen the comedian helped
get me on there and bruce baum
made sure that i could get on there so
did you get any advice from any of these
people that you remember that was
helpful at all bob or you just were
figuring it out by yourself or what
robin came up to me and my act was just
all esoteric weird things
i would say i have no friends and i have
no life and i live in a moped
and my mother is gumby and my father is
pokey and i'm mr potato head
was all the same rhythm with different
words and
robin came williams came over to me and
i just got off stage and when people are
coming over to you
that you know are the are the ones that
are
really good uh it's it's a pretty
exceptional thing
that happened at in my at 22 years old
and robin came over and he went so your
mother's gonna be in your father's pokey
and you're mr potato head
and i went yep he went okay
and then we talked for a little bit and
then you know we just
and then it's funny because dave coulier
had moved out
um to l.a and then he was and robin said
oh who's he
the the winged angel that does popeye
and that was before robin
before robin had just done uh the sequel
to laugh in bro
you know laugh into before mork and
mindy
and he people just know
you know who's good you know you could
tell right and
robin complimented me by letting me
know that he thought i was somebody he
wanted to talk to
um right and and then it was just a very
interesting time and then i was there
for eight years
and i ended up emceeing so you know just
getting started for me
was a very long just getting started and
it always is it's
i have seven year phases where i scare
people and then i don't anymore
and then if people misinterpret me grow
on people bob you grow on people
so does algae you know fungi
mouth sores there's many things so this
is so
uh fascinating we never had this
conversation
no but that's what this this is what
this pod is all about
[Music]
today's episode of just getting started
is brought to you by first leaf
who hasn't been there you're standing in
the wine aisle staring at the shelves do
you want a california red maybe one from
oregon something organic maybe just the
one with the really nice label
do you even know what's any good maybe
you need someone to help you
maybe you need that confidence to grab
that bottle open it up and enjoy it
thankfully there's first leaf a better
way to discover wine at a fraction of
the price you'll find in a store
first leaf is a fully customizable wine
club that sends
curated boxes of wine that are perfect
for you and they have more award-winning
wine than
anyone else with first leaf this is
important there's no guesswork
no misguided recommendations from an
employee who doesn't know what you like
and no frustration on your part
each wine shipment is entirely
customized to your unique palette
and preferences unlike big box wine
membership
first leaf uses a one-of-a-kind
algorithm and your feedback
to curate future wine recommendations
the more wines you taste and review
the better the shipments get first leaf
works directly with the world's
best wine makers not only to find the
best wines available but then to pass
the savings
on to you saving you up to 60
off retail save time money and stress
with first leaf
the wine club designed with you in mind
it is so awesome you put in your
preferences
and you get a one you like think about
that join today and you'll get
six bottles of wine for 29.95
and free shipping just go to
tryfirstleaf.com
eisen that's six bottles of wine for
29.95 and free shipping
try it at tryfirstleaf.com that's
tryfirstleaf.com
[Applause]
what would you consider your your
biggest break
outside of obviously walking into a
the comedy store just at its height and
zenith and then you have
you know all of these people as your
colleagues by right
well they weren't my colleagues they
were my they were my elders you know
they they were then you became
they became your colleagues though you
know in a long time some of them but
when arsenio went off to do arsenio and
i was still hosting the main room
yes i was bringing out eddie murphy and
richard pryor but i wanted to be on
television
and then howie years before went and did
say elsewhere
and i love them so it wasn't competitive
it was like
well i want to be on i want to work um
and then i guess one there are two
things that happened for me that were
significant yes and that
that was uh the rodney dangerfields his
very first young comedian special
and um i actually introduced him to sam
kennison because sam had i met in
houston
sam came out to the comedy store and um
i told mitzi to watch him but two other
people had already called so he didn't
need me
and then once he got on stage at the
comedy store he didn't need anybody
you know it was it was this amazing uh
yeah so is that how sam kinnison wound
up in back to school
because you you introduced yeah well i
would i wouldn't say i'm the reason i
you know i would say that it would
happen anyway sure but i
did i was there saying rodney this is
sam kennison
and then roddy went excuse me bob
sam sam man man i can't believe it man
um you're unbelievable and he um
rodney was just you know he put me on
that young comedian special i was on
before sam
and uh i had a 15-minute set i did
really well
um and then sam blew the roof off the
room
and that made my set four minutes long
and sam's was you know 12 minutes or
something
he was the fire explosion out of the
special and
but that still was incredibly
significant for me and
uh it meant a great deal to me and then
the next thing that happened a couple
years later
because of course you never think you're
going to work again and richard pryor
uh he did a movie called critical
condition
and on an open audition marjorie simkin
was the casting director and i met
michael apted
and was in a movie called critical
condition
and that was um being able to work with
richard and joe montagna and
that was my second start i was getting
older already i was
26 or something and then i thought i'd
never work again
and then um and then i
did a lot of road you know i did a lot
of touring
did a bunch of shows did guest spots on
shows and then
finally uh got the show on cbs
the morning program and then got fired
from that
because i was too hot for morning
television i would imagine
wait a minute i just because we we all
know what happens in your career
and where where we eventually get to for
right you know you're the biggest
pop culture well we don't know yet cause
we're still gonna watch this new thing
that's gonna happen because i'm
different now i mean
bill burr is probably telling you it's
different now you know when we go out
and do comedy
which i have to do more than ever sure
it's really different now
for me it means more to me it means even
more to me
i i feel like i have a responsibility
now almost in a fatherly sense
to not to if i'm going to cross
boundaries i better
tee it up really well if i'm gonna say
something horrific
as a joke of how horrific things are
there's a comment on it i better have a
two minute
tee up and then a three minute apology
prepared and ready to
you know it just it just becomes
conversational it's more it's more of a
conversation now
than it's ever been with me than just
joke joke it just doesn't it's not the
same anymore
right so um oh why did i get fired from
the cbs no yeah because like i said i
i've never heard that you did a cb
did you look was that a national gig or
was that a yeah it was on against the
today show good morning america it was
the predecessor
it was before that but they turned it
over you're ready for this you'll
appreciate this
to the entertainment division now cbs
news
didn't take too kindly to that that's
not what cbs news
wants to do is turn it over to the
entertainment division yes mr paley
uh did not build the news division so it
can be turned over to in the
entertainment division
so that's that so you were doing what
like good morning
i was the host no i was
third banana okay the the hosts
were married hartley and um right the
actress married hartley and roland smith
who had
been he's a hardcore newsman yeah
hardcore newsman
and then mark mcewen dear mark mcewen
was
the weather and music coverage of all
music acts
and he um was there for you know 10 to
12 years or something then he went to
florida after that but
this show lasted nine months but i
lasted five months
because one morning marriott hartley
said bob are you a type a person
i would be there for chat you know just
to chat to be the humorous chat like
drive radio
but let's bob shanks who started good
morning america and wrote the book
i don't know if you remember the book
the cool fire but it was about
television
he was he's a historic man he hired me
off of a william morris sample tape
and then i'm there and marion hartley
says
are you a type a person and i said yes
but i'm trying to work on my anus
and what i meant was a dash and ess
but it sounded like anus so they sent me
to my room
and my room didn't exist there was a
stairs and then
a door and the commercial breaks were
they were
13 minutes apart because it was 1987
six and i had to stand behind a flat
for like 10 minutes they didn't let me
come back down and i knew right then and
there
that i would no longer be on the show
and then the following week
i was just going it's 15 minutes after
the hour
off camera so i had and i was
discovering comedians they would have i
would have comedians on like roseanne
and
and joy bahar and different people so is
this why al roker never said here's
what's going on in your neck of the ass
bob is that is that here's what's good
your head up my ass with your neck
you're up to your neck and now i took it
too far yeah no no no it's okay
it's all right but maybe you're you know
you you
you you're aiming well i'll roker and i
to no well let me explain
uh al roker and i one time played
chicken in a pool so
i he was on my shoulders so that
actually did happen
[Music]
[Applause]
do you own or rent your home sure you do
and i bet it could be hard work
you know what's easy bundling policies
with geico
geico makes it easy to bundle your
homeowners or renters insurance
along with your auto policy it's a good
thing too because you already have so
much to do around your home
go to geico.com get a quote and see how
much you could save
it's geico easy visit geico.com today
that's geico.com
today's episode of just getting started
is brought to you by netsuite
if you're a business owner you might be
making running your business
harder on yourself than necessary stop
paying for multiple systems that don't
give you the information you need when
you need it
ditch the spreadsheets and all the old
software that you've clearly outgrown
now is the time to upgrade to netsuite
by oracle the world's number one cloud
business system
netsuite gives you visibility and
control over your financials
hr inventory e-commerce and more
everything you need
all in one place instantaneously
whether you're doing a million or
hundreds of millions in revenue
save time and money with netsuite join
the over
24 000 companies using netsuite right
now
let netsuite show you how they'll
benefit your business with a free
product tour at netsuite.com so
schedule your free product tour right
now at netsuite.com e-i-s-e-n that's
netsuite.com
[Applause]
when did the uh when did america's uh
home videos
come your way well that what happened
was uh when i got fired
from the morning program my manager brad
gray called jeff franklin because they
wanted me originally for full house
and they they removed an actor who was
very good in the part
and they hired me after i screen tested
and then i did the pilot and then we did
the series full house and a year later
um i was sent a tape of these first
videos that were in the very first
pilot of america's funniest home videos
and uh they had seen me on the tonight
show with johnny
showing a video of my wedding and
narrating it and thought i'd be the good
host
one of the producers from america's
funny it's not vinda bono but steve
pasquet
is his name sure and i ended up um
doing the pilot for this show that we
thought was going to be a special
and then it was airing and i got a phone
call because i had been friendly
with tom hanks because i used to do the
warm-up for bosom buddies
so i get a call from tom and he goes
what the hell is this
what am i watching i said i don't know
they had me host these
clips and it's just people people
sending in tapes
and he said this is the most amazing
thing i've ever seen in my life
this is are you kidding me he says i
gotta go i gotta watch this
and i just remember i was holding my
firstborn
and we were watching it and in sherman
oaks
and it the next day we got to pick up
for
13 episodes and then the following year
it moved to number one very quickly it
preceded
youtube bob it preceded youtube there
was no people
yeah but i'm serious like people like
people now there's websites where people
post their videos there was
this preceded the whole idea of you know
uh everything from you know vacation
video to
nut shots to all of that stuff you know
i was the i always say i was the
gatekeeper of the nut hit
if you wanted to see somebody get hit in
the nads
you had to go through me i was standing
by the gate
the nut the gate the tap the nipper
exactly you just tap your nuts on the
gate and i let you in
and and sports videos we'd have you know
and it's the one where the guy
goes over the fence to catch the ball
and his pants get hooked on the fence in
his pants if your pants fall off
and it's not set up you're gonna win ten
thousand dollars
[Music]
that's how life works now oh that is so
damn funny and uh again and then we'll
before we get to the here and now with
you
full house um that was at the time
something that you got and this is
because you said you wanted to be on tv
and you saw what people were doing
it was a dream because it was done by
miller boyette and
um and jeff franklin who i'd known
because he was a writer on lebron
shirley and i knew him from
from bosom buddies and and bob boyet and
tom miller
the producers knew me from bosom buddies
because i
they even put me on the show once as a
warm-up guy audience warm-up guy
and then um they'd also seen me in in
the richard pryor movie so that
happened it didn't do well for the first
four years people always thought it was
on fridays it was on tuesdays and we
were on against seinfeld
and they weren't doing well right first
couple years so we were competing
against each other not doing well
drawing different audiences right um and
i was excited about it because i love
acting
and it was a character and and
i said let's make him like felix anger
let's make him a neat freak and i want
to hug
people because i hug people not the past
year and a half but i
i do um and then uh next thing i knew
they just
they thought that that's what i'm like
and you can't deviate from that
if that's what they think you're like um
and anthony hopkins eats people we know
that because
once you're hannibal i believe the
characters are who they play
of course they are yeah yeah yeah
if tom cruise can do his own stunts and
also
cancel the golden globes then he is the
guy for mission impossible
he is that guy you just cracked me up
you always have bob
you're nice no i'm not it's it's the
truth it's just the truth and i i didn't
know
i've known you for a long time but i
didn't know a lot about this and
like you warmed up the crowd for bosom
buddies that had to have been
amazing chris thompson was
my friend and um and incredibly funny
guy he originated the show and gary
shandling introduced me to him in the
bathroom at the comedy store
right so that was the early 80s so you
can only imagine the antics
uh and um but it was uh
it was a cool thing i'd still would go
on the road and then uh my friend barry
diamond would fill in for me while i was
doing
the road and then come back to do the
warm-up
it's a good experience for a person
that's starting out to do television
warm-up because god there's a guy ron
pearson
who is doing fuller house for a long
time and he's so
talented you know and you end up with
hours and hours of material
and if that's one route you want to go
the other is you know
strictly do the circuit or find the
places where you can get a stage if you
want to do stand-up
so so let's get to the here and now
you're back on the road people can go
get tickets and see where you are at
bobsage.com right or is it done
that is correct okay yes so you're gonna
be updating that website and put your
picture on it so that you'll be able to
take responsibility for anything
um i'm not putting your email on it and
most people can
yeah let's say you normally work so
clean when i see you on tv rich like
what happened
like the usual i am cleaner
i am oddly cleaner i i i don't have the
desire
i mean everybody drops the
f-bomb once in a while sure but not
everybody i mean some people are smart
but i
i just talked away i kind of talk but i
don't i'm not that much different than
this
it's a conversation and you know i'm
almost 65 even though um
from the waist down i i look about about
eight
um but
um wow i might gotta recover from that
comment no it's okay
bob it's fine i saw the instagram
photograph that you put out there
people thought that was real all i did
was put it on face tune and take
my my waist and push it all the way to
the point
where there's no room for a spine or
internal organs
and my wife kelly said no make it
thinner make it like an hourglass people
are gonna think
that it's real yeah i went no no they're
not it's an obvious photoshop
um and then people are going this is
photoshopped
like okay gen z have a nice time
not understanding anything but um
the truth of it is yeah i'm
more in love with what i'm doing now
i've got a thing i'm gonna direct we're
getting it set up now i just did a movie
in the cayman islands during
golden cove quarantine i was able to go
there and do this movie called blue
iguana
which i think is going to be called
killing daniel but it's
it was directed by jeremy lalonde who's
very good and it
had really good people and it was uh
joel david moore and jason jones
and carly chakin and marilyn rice cub
and uh and chantal riley all good people
and so
we'll see how that does and uh then
you're not
look at my podcast is your pod bob
saggett's here for you now now walk me
through how that
how you did that well started off i
started it
uh at the beginning of this podcast that
was you can really
take out everything about me because it
goes right to here
no that's how i started incorrectly i
don't know i didn't get the concept
of your show which i like because it's
great because people like
people do like hearing about how people
started of course because they're trying
to figure out how can i make my way in
the world if i want to be an athlete if
i want to be
anything no matter what i want to do i
want to run a company
i say bitcoin everybody that's the way
to go
everybody everybody uh who has it i'm
joking by the way
i would never know if i meant it no no
everyone has a
a start and everybody's trying to if you
will work on their anus
bob you know they're they're in yes
you're actually the answer is type a
is the answer i'm a workaholic i've
always worked very hard
i'm not satisfied unless i work really
hard
so you know if i'm not around
well nobody's been able to be that
around during this time i was able to do
a movie and do some stand-up which is a
miracle
but wouldn't be and be on some shows
like the mass singer
you know it's like oh god
i can't believe i didn't reach out to
you oh my god
what happened is for three years they
said you want to be on it i'm like
no i'm good you know i'm okay i don't
want to be in a mascot suit i'm fine
and i you know and then ken jong's a
friend robin thicke's a friend because i
was very close with his dad and
and then one day after six months of
quarantine they said
craig plestis said you want to be honest
to pick me up pick me up
test me every day put me in a mascot
suit put a visor on me
beat me with a fungo bat i don't care
what you do to me
i'll sing anything with a head that
weighs 40 pounds cut off my larynx
kill me i don't care what you do to me i
can't i got to be around people even if
i'm not allowed
and i i enjoyed it i enjoyed it but um
the truth of it is now i'm about to
start a tour tour
so i can um uh go out and
and then do a new special at the end of
the year which i'll be doing
and um and i'll be telling people when
that's
gonna be and so they can come to it and
then see it when we know when it is
and i'm also working on um a bunch of a
bunch of stuff i got
things in development as they say uh
because i don't want to
people say stuff sometimes like oh i'm
doing this and that but
you know even if you read it in deadline
hollywood it doesn't mean
that it's it's got you gotta it's gotta
be out you gotta see somebody saying
this will be on this streamer tuesday
you're on every day yeah i'm on too much
bob
i'm trying to be present for my kids you
know but here he hit funny things so
kids are not as important as a career
[Laughter]
you know what i got to write that down
um
uh teach it to your kids have them go
around saying it
because we watch the math singer all the
time my kids watch the mass singer all
the time
and the number of times that my wife and
i sit there with the reveal
and we're like look at each other like
who is that person or for real
and then when you get revealed for us to
be able to tell our children
you have no idea how long we've known
this man we know this man we actually
were you surprised this guy oh are you
surprised
uh yeah bob to say the least
some people were not like candace uh
cameron beret
my daughter from full house in fuller
house knows my voice so she
started screaming and they got mad at
her because it was a spoiler alert on
on her instagram that's bob oh my god
that's oh my god
oh my god yeah i mean you know we know
your voice and your cadence i would say
but not
not enough to you know see cut through
all of this stuff
and you know for us we we're we're
trying to relate to our children with
with this show and our and best we can
because it's family television it's kind
of like what it's like
what what all those appointment
television shows used to be
it's really quite an amazing success so
many people love it
they do they love it and you know they
always sit there and so here's the rule
they always think it is the most famous
person in the world underneath the mask
they always think that so and then i
took my head off
that's not the point i i where where
there is a rock
so here's so here's it there's a there's
a deal in the house and this
god bless them they're still so young
where they this is the the um
this is the drama part of the drama of
the reveal in the house for the mass
singer
they get one hundred dollars if it's an
obama
of any name and obama beyonce or lebron
james
if it isn't obama lebron james or
beyonce because they're always thinking
they will get one a crisp one hundred
dollar bill from dad
that's terrible you're paying your it's
a gift if they get
because i keep telling them they keep
saying oh it's got to be barack obama or
it's beyonce oh it's just lebron james
i'm like it's not and they're like what
if it is
if it is i give you a hundred dollars i
love that your kids don't know how
showbiz works
that lebron james is not getting in that
case
i'll tell you the only person that might
never get in it that i wouldn't
be shocked is kevin hart because he
literally is in
every single medium that exists
and he's so amazing at everything but i
don't think he would have time to do
what you need to do
because you got to rehearse you have to
work yes but i
i don't think you're going to see movie
stars that are out working movie after
movie
being able to put the amount of time in
right what about the 44th president of
the united states like they're like
that's barack obama i'm like
right as a matter of fact we'll just
broaden the entire scope
sasha malia uh or michelle as well
annie obama naaman obama king james
or the or beyonce they get a hundred
dollars what about george w
do you think he would do it i don't
think so i don't but
pictures of dogs he might come out as a
little puppy and that's the biggest hint
ever
what were you again what was your
costume again squiggly monster
and i chose it because it looked like a
lot of boobs all over my body
and and i'm sorry everybody if that
offends anybody i'm talking
like not nor like another planet you
know i mean
you know i i don't know what to do
because i don't i don't know
i look like something from another world
you know it doesn't
and they looked and i wanted the
eyeballs to twirl
and they said they can't do that they
have to be fixed
i said people are gonna think well i
said people are gonna think they're
boobs
man boobs and uh they said uh we don't
know
if he's a man or woman and i said i am
so invested in this character
um and i had four arms and lobster claws
and to keep me calm they had a bucket of
drawn butter for me
in the back i'll tell you who i was
really pissed off at is uh
paul anka who i never knew was broccoli
now if you're telling me that i'm
competitive
with broccoli then you know that i'm
having it's either the pandemic
or i got career problems or both i'm
angry that paul anka is broccoli
i i don't know this funny thing is just
i guess to bring this all full circle
back to my parents
for some reason i don't understand why
my parents i grew up
with with them telling me that they had
such an animus a hatred for paul anka i
don't know why
he never did anything to her yes my
mother
but it was easy he wrote so many great
songs i don't know the tonight
show theme too i mean all of it i don't
know why
so he wrote he wrote the lyrics to my
way
i don't know what i don't know i don't
know what to say other than the fact
that for some reason when paul ankle was
revealed
as broccoli and i called my mom up i'm
like guess who was revealed oh
like honestly you get that's the the
voice was it a height thing are they
are they are they i don't know i don't
know but do they
profile height of people i don't know
i don't know but this every single five
minutes in this conversation something's
come up that's reminded me of my own
past
my her mother's right my grandmother's
name was grandma minnie
so you went to grandma minnie's uh you
know uh comedy show that's interesting
it's not my
it was not my grandma mini i know that
for a fact so it's really no
it was actually the owner's grandma
there you go so there was another mini
and philly what city did you come out of
staten island new york sir
grandma when he was in brooklyn that's
basically pete davidson is the mayor at
this point that's right exactly
so bob saget's here for new you every
episode
uh new episodes come out every monday
tiffany haddish jason zedakis whoopi
goldberg norman lear
uh just some of the guests chelsea
handler is this week joel mchale's is
next
great guest list bob i can't wait to
yeah and there and most are friends or
people that i've known for years or
people that i just reach out to and i be
like jake tapper i just reached out
online and he goes you don't know how
much this means to me
your mother and my mother worked at
children's hospital in philadelphia
and when you were 20 when you were in
college when you were 19
18 years old your mother would tell my
mother at lunch
that you were gonna be my bobby's gonna
be a big star one day
and jake said as a kid he had to listen
to this because he's
a lot younger than me but it was so
interesting to have a connection
this we all have a connection that we
don't we're not even aware of you know
right
and you you should have jake's my guest
next week i've known him for years you
will love him the two of you will just i
i adore him i mean he is what is that
his new book
looks like exactly what you and i would
love it's about sinatra
and and uh and reagan and all that
it's it's gonna be amazing next week and
everybody should get your podcast bob
sagets here for you bobsagat.com
to check out the new stand-up tour
adding eight uh dates to a daily from
june onward bob i love you man thanks
for doing this
i love i love you rich i really like you
and and i love your wife even though
she's been in many many men's locker
rooms
just like in any given sunday is that it
and isn't that the name of it was that
the name it's a football movie yeah yeah
yeah well they had cameron diaz in the
locker room interviewing all the players
nude
out of the shower and it was no big
whoop i mean it was but it wasn't and
susie kind of did that she was in locker
rooms and she told me about it
and she i think she dreams about it
i do hear her screaming about randy
johnson every now and then and i wonder
what the hell that's all about so
well how do you get a last name like
that i mean
it's right there on the wall his
nickname was the big unit for a reason
bob
that was oh my god and my last name is
saget and i did not choose it because
that's not a name you choose
you have a great name it's almost like
einstein it makes us sound like you're
smart
i love you bob saget thanks for coming
on i love you rich eisen that's bob
saget here on just getting started
oh my gosh my uh my face is hurting i'm
wondering if yours
are as well wherever you're taking in
this edition of just getting started and
there's a lot to take in right there
from bob but here's the one thing that i
take away from it
because it's similar to my experience
that i had when i got to
espn at age 26 he referred to himself as
an older comedian at age 26
because he had done what he was doing
fresh out of college starting off at the
comedy store in los angeles and seeing
all of these people he referred to as
his elders not his colleagues
um folks like letterman and leno and
robin williams and richard pryor and so
on and so forth and rodney dangerfield
but they are his colleagues now and they
were at the time as well and it's
interesting he referred to as i said
them as his elders and that is a way
that i
walked into espn at age 26 um where i
was struck by lightning i've told this
story a few times if you hadn't heard
some of this before
um i share my my own personal
experiences
here on on the podcast coming out of the
interview
um where i i pull on a little bit of a
strand from what i just heard from my
guest
from their origin story experience if it
dovetails with mine
or reminds me of of a moment of mice of
my own
but i was age 26 when i was hired and
found
in reading california a small market
community tv uh demographic
tv station in reading chico area uh
north way north of of sacramento in
northern california it's near
closer to oregon than anywhere else espn
hired me found me their age 26
i wind up in the espn community
in the newsroom at espn where there were
uh dozens and dozens of people
more you know jam-packed with human
beings
more than just the 12 that i was working
with in this small station and the
people who i am now working with
and being thrown in the mix are people
who
i revered and idolized watching on
television from chris berman to
my buddy dan patrick and keith olbermann
and
bob lee and robin roberts and charlie
steiner and
um craig kilbourne i mean my gosh
um it was amazing and
daunting at the same time but i i didn't
let it faze me
and that's what i think was pretty neat
about bob there
um in the same way that he got advice
from robin williams about his
uh his delivery or his material i got
the same stuff from keith olbermann
um where he took an interest and it was
humbling and also could have been very
overwhelming and it was at times to get
that advice
unvarnished from from keith um
but i i refuse to be overwhelmed by it
at times i did feel inferior i felt very
inferior sometimes
uh wondering if i'll ever get to the
point where i could be in their
league uh in terms of experience
um and how many sports center reps it
would take for me to actually
be in the realm uh of that
um class of broadcaster that say keith
or dan were in and you know eventually i
i i
felt more and more comfortable day in
and day out but you could be
you know thrown in a mix of a new
situation for yourself
and you've been hired or you've gotten
the opportunity
because thankfully somebody saw
something in you or you
twisted an arm or you used a
relationship to get into this spot
then you might be looking around and
thinking to yourself do you really
belong
do you really have what it takes to be
in this room
and all i would say to you is you got in
the room
so the answer is yes the question is
what are you going to do with the
opportunity
what are you going to do and being
overwhelmed by
your surroundings and who else is in the
room with you despite their level of
experience
or um level of success
it's to me having that overwhelm you
is a waste of your energy because
you got there and all you got to do is
get in the room get that one opportunity
and go for it and that's what it
reminded me of when
bob was telling the story of all these
people that were there and that's why i
said they're your colleagues he said no
they were my elders
but they eventually became his
colleagues you know even though
technically some of them are his elders
in terms of age
but if you're good at what you do it's
ageless
it's basically what i'm trying to say
and that's it for this episode of just
getting started my buddy jake tapper of
cnn
and this new remarkable novel
called um uh the devil may dance
wait till you uh hear about jake's
origin stories and how he has made
himself into what he is today
so thanks for taking this episode of
just getting started we'll see you
next wednesday
you